за уста не п'ю туру року в Україні сенс
і сотні пам'яток лінину перейменовувати
у усмішці то на ці місця троянському та
названої влада україни
засудила тоталітарний режим СРСР і закон
удача забурчало комуністичну
ідеологію чи то символіку
літр київських комуністів Олександр
кімнаті кай поважаєш що його партія
чоловіки справедливо за вартою датою через
краще на радіо низьких частин
наша партія організувалася нашим арте
організувалася у дев'яносто п'ятому уроці
ми сучасна партія носа приватних умовах
заради омський союз розлочений цифри
праворуч істориків один такт інших
учасників майдану Олександр Данилюк
поважна компартія по ви на по стежки ти
адже за оборону на розродитися, що вийшла
і манула алізаде реальність втомимося і
рукам і ось тому числи і , мку режиму
януковича
чайни мало ніби за барона не просто
банально через t жартів вимагаючи на
сьогоднішній не український закон доступу
що за барона на діяльність
політичних партій ідеальності яких
спрямовано самий на пружині курс
сигналом на виборах 2014 року комуністи
втішено пружини до верховної ради
хочеш 4-ро до того за них проголосувало
над два з половиною мільйони вибір
tell політолог Володимир фесенко у темні
поспішаючи називає такою партію
політичним трупом можна став така
ситуація акція була на підрахунку
above польші може змінити назву так а
самі комуністи повернуться схожий на
такий сценарій одягаєте і самі
комуністи будинку з цілих ви давайте
5 жовта
їх на допустив і alavann і все ж таки взяв і
юних доля засіки у складі сую нульових
лдпр комуністи
пакла дайте надіюсь на європейський суд
справлю ден і куди в брайті скаже якщо
вона за барону за діалоги чотирма куань